[SQUEAKING]
[RUSTLING] [CLICKING]
PROFESSOR: Welcome back to 8701.
In the second chapter, we
will discuss symmetries
and the importance of symmetries
in physics in general,
but also especially in particle
physics and nuclear physics.
So we start with a short
introductory video,
and then we'll move on to
more details as we go along.
The importance of symmetries
cannot be understated
in physics.
And there's two aspects
which are important.
The first one is that
symmetries and conservation
laws go hand in hand, as
discussed by Noether's theorem.
To express the theorem
in an informal way,
you can say that if a system
has a continuous symmetry
property, then there are
corresponding properties whose
values do not change with time,
meaning that they're conserved.
You can express this
more sophisticated,
and say to every differentiable
symmetry generated
by local action,
there's correspondence.
There's a correspondent
conserved current.
And we're going to look at
those actions and currents
as we go along.
The second aspect,
beyond the fact
that there's
conservation laws, is
that you can understand
physics experiments and nature
if you know that physics
has an underlying symmetry,
without fully
understanding the physics
or the mathematical
backgrounds in order
to do calculation in detail.
So knowing that there
is underlying symmetry
can help in really expressing
or understanding the physics
behavior of experiments.
A few historic remarks
on Emmy Noether--
Emmy Noether was born in Germany
in the 1880s in Erlangen,
where she grew up
and also studied
Mathematics at the University
of Erlangen. After getting
her degree, she worked
for a full seven years
at the university in
the Math Department,
and received zero
dollars, and not
just because it wasn't the
currency being used there,
but at that time,
women didn't really
have a prominent
role in academia.
And so there was no
job for her to take.
But her talents and
her qualification
was seen in the mathematical
world at the time,
specifically in the center
of the mathematical world,
which was in Goettingen.
So Hilbert basically
discovered her, and asked her
to come to Goettingen. In order
to do habilitation, she did get
an habilitation in Goettingen
in 1919, and then
stayed in Goettingen
till the situation in Europe
degraded in the 1930s.
She was born Jewish and
couldn't stay in Goettingen
beyond the year
1933, and then had
to immigrate into
the United States,
where she worked at
Bryn Mawr College,
and also with Princeton.
Her work-- you see here
her habilitation, which
is in German
[SPEAKING GERMAN],, "Invariant
Variation of Problems,"
was highly regarded.
And she had a lot of
influence and impact
on various strands of
mathematics and physics.
Unfortunately, she
passed away already
when she was about 50 years old.
She was diagnosed with
some sort of cancer,
and passed away really,
really quickly after this,
after some surgery.
Her temperature rose and a few
days later, she passed away.
To come back to symmetries
and conservation laws,
every symmetry of nature
uses a conservation law.
That is what Noether's
theorem tells you.
And you can reverse
this to saying
that every conservation
law in physics
reflects an underlying symmetry.
And examples for
this are the fact
that the properties,
the laws of physics
are invariant on the
time translation, meaning
that physics is the same
yesterday, the same tomorrow,
and it's going to be
the same next week.
And out of this, we can
deduce energy conservation.
Similarly, translation
in space results
in a momentum
conservation, angular
rotations or rotations
without the angular momentum.
And then a little
bit harder to grasp,
but we will see
this in more detail,
internal symmetries can also
lead to conservation laws.
And gauge transformation leads
to the conservation of charge.
So there is internal
symmetries as well.
Before we dive into more
detail, a few things.
First, in many cases,
symmetry operations
can be expressed via
matrices or groups.
And there's a few
rules or operations
which are rather important
and define symmetry.
The first one is that
any symmetry operation
has to have identity,
meaning there
has to be an operation
which doesn't do anything
with an element of this group.
There has to be closure,
meaning that if you apply
a first transformation
and then a second,
the resulting transformation
is, again, part
of the set of transformations.
And there is an inverse, meaning
that if you rotate in one
direction, you can rotate back.
And there's
associativity, meaning
that if you have a rotation
acting on two other rotations,
you can regroup and follow
what's shown in this equation
here.
It's not clear that
you can reverse
the order of certain elements
of your group or your symmetry
operation.
You can classify them, however.
Those where you can commute,
those are called abelian
groups, and those that you
cannot, those are non-abelian.
All right, so with this,
we have introduced,
with the first
video, symmetries.
And now, we just
dive into more detail
in understanding continuous
symmetries and also
discrete symmetries, and
what we can learn from them.